for most Canadians this is the first
restriction free Christmas since the
pandemic but Canada's top doctor is
warning covid-19 could still unleash new
problems overall the virus is still a
young in terms of his circulation in the
human population even though we're fed
up with it in her year-end interview
with global news Dr Teresa Tam
urged Canadians to take precautions with
covid-19 RSV and the flu all circulating
at high levels we can write our own
story as to what happens post-holiday
season if we took these measures we will
come out of this next weeks the next
couple of weeks
um and and more safely but with
hospitals overwhelmed healthcare workers
on the front line are frustrated saying
the federal government's messaging does
not go far enough this is the first
um you know Christmas holiday period
where we've gone into it buck naked in
terms of any public health policies
Omicron arrived around this time last
year and spread rapidly over the
holidays and the months that followed
since then it's become the dominant
strain and there are fears about new
strains with covid-19 cases exploding in
China Beijing backed away from its zero
coveted policy after unprecedented
protests since then cases have swelled
in a population with little immunity
whenever the nurses spreading anyway
potential for variants to emerge
modeling by a British research firm
shows China is dealing with a million
new coveted cases daily and is expected
to be the world's biggest outbreak it's
likely that those numbers will not be
officially given by the Chinese
government if you have an explosion of
cases in other countries whether it be
China the U.S or anywhere in the world
that's going to have an impact here so
doctors are urging people wherever they
travel whether it's between countries or
between households to remember the
pandemic is not over teria Israeli
Global News
Ottawa